الاغنيه السعوديه عاشت بجناح واحد طول
فتره عمرها حتى الان هي لا زالت تعيش
بجناح واحد فقط الجناح اللي هو المادي
اللي احنا نسميه المؤسسات الماديه توفر
لها فرصه مؤسسات انتاج خدمات انتاجيه ايضا
خدمات تسويقيه
خدمات ترويجيه العلاقه زي بالحفلات يعني
وهيئه الترفيه هذه نتائج التراكم لكن حرمت
او ربما الاغنيه السعوديه هي حرمت نفسها
يعني كيف حرمت نفسها حرمت من الجناح
الثاني اللي هو مؤسسات التنشئه اللي هو
الاعتراف الاكاديمي التربوي دخولها من باب
من بوابه التعليم تنشئه التدريب لا زلت
الحقبه اللي كان فيها مثلا المؤسسه
الدينيه هي المسيطره مثلا على
خلينا نقول من يضع ارتبط واستراتيجيه
التعليم لم يكن في ذهنهم ذكل فتره
يبرمجون في المناهج وجود مواد خاصه
بالفنون كلها سواء يعني المسرح او
الغناء او العزف طبعا يعني داخل مناهج
التعليم العام يعني
هذا يمهد فيما بعد المعاهد او الكليات
المتخصصه يعني للان ننتظرها تعمل حتى الان
يعني لكن مؤسسه او المدرسه موسيقات الجيش
اللي اشتغلت ما بين الخمسينات حتى وتوقفت
في اول السبعينات
حيث تدرس الات نفخ والات نقر لكن الموسيقى
العسكريه لا علاقه لها بالغناء العربي هي
تؤدي فقط انماط معينه لها علاقه
بالاستقبال والتوديع مسائل دبلوماسيه
وسياسيه طبعا لكن هي لا يقوم عليها لعب
لتطوير او تنشئه واليوم
مع وجود هيئه الترفيه مع وجود برامج
وهيئات الموسيقى هيئه للثقافه الادب
وغيرها من الامه شو اللي تغير كيف ممكن
ننظر الى مستقبل الاغنيه السعودي
يعني الخبره اللي اكتسبتها الاغنيه
السعوديه من خلال مسائل تجربتها الانتاجيه
العميقه وتعدد شركات الانتاج بالاضافه الى
انه الشركات الانتاج السعوديه استطاعت ان
تضم حتى اصوات عربيه والدليل نرى الان
هيئه الترفيه تستطيع انها تستضيف
ليالي مخصصه حتى الفنانين غير سعوديين
يعني مثل الليالي تكريم لبعض الملحنين
العرب او المغنيين العرب طبعا وهذا
استمرار للتراكم اللي اكتسبته لكن ننتظر
مثلا انا او غيري
الكثير ننتظر مثلا ماذا يمكن ان تفعل
القطاعات التعليميه سواء التعليم عام او
تعليم عالي ماذا ستقدم من برامج متخصصه هل
ستعيد اخطاء برامج التعليم في العالم
العربي والعالم ايضا الاخر او السعوديه
بالفتره اللي كانوا يعاني فيها الفنانين
من المضايقات من فتاوى التحريم
برايك ابدا كانت اخصم فتره في الانتاج
وفتره يعني اوقف كان هناك تميز انك ترى
جمالا
زمن الجميل ممكن تقول انها كان زمن ذهبي
الاغنيه السعوديه لانه هو مركزها تجاريا
ونشرها بشكل جيد لانه الكسر لو دور كان
يمكن في الانتشار اكثر من الاسطوانه
الاسطوانه للاسف معرضه بالتنقل للكسر
الكسر ممكن تعطي ترخيص في دول اخرى وتطبعه
من جديد ما كان هذا متوفر حتى الكاتريج ما
كان متوفر في الاجهزه تشغيله الا سيارات
معينه تقد حتى اجهزه معينه لما ظهر
باعتباره بديل بعد الاسطوانات لكن الكاسيت
لا اعطى فرصه اقدر اقول ان المرحله
الثالثه من الاغنيه السعوديه كانت هي بنت
الكاسيت واعطاها فرصه
انتشار كبير هذا ما في شك بالاضافه لانه
ظهر جيل مهم في الثمانينات ملحنين وشعراء
وفنانين ما زال هم المتسيدين يعني